bonjour et andré martin bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france pour décrypter ces premiers
résultats officiels partiels encore eu
la td ou qui n'a jamais enregistré un
tel score moins de 30% des voix comment
est-ce que vous analyser cette défaite
cuisante pour angela merkel
bien un ensemble de facteurs je pense
qu'ils ont qui a joué le premier facteur
c'est le fait que la succession de
madame merkel a été très difficile à
organiser
je vous rapelle que au
départ c'était madame crunk aaron bauer
qui avait été désigné comme dauphine et
que suite aux eaux aux élections
thuringe en février 2020 avait été
obligé de démissionner il avait fallu
remettre en en plus en piste 1 un
successeur ce qui avait été assez
difficile et monsieur l'achète s'est
imposé sur la la décision des caciques
du parti mais c'est quelqu'un qui
n'avait qui n'a jamais eu la possibilité
de gagner les coeurs et les âmes des
militants cd ou et en plus de ça il a
fait de campagne relativement maladroite
il a été beaucoup dans l'attentisme et
il n'a pas réussi à
démontrer un style particulier qui
aurait entraîné derrière lui les
militants et lui permettre aussi aller
au delà de la base cd dont ils le payent
chèrement ce soir est-ce que sur le plan
du bilan donc gala merkel est ce que ça
a joué
ma disons que le l'ombre de main de
madame merkel a plané sur ces élections
mais personne n'a vraiment pratiqué un
droit d'inventaire sur son sur son bilan
les critiques sont restés extrêmement
feutrée et peut-être qu'il a il
appartenait à monsieur l'achète de faire
ce bilan pour montrer qu'en même temps
qu'il allait donner des accents nouveau
à la politique menée par l'allemagne
mais
il faut bien voir que la figure
tutélaire de madame merkel reste très
présente et que personne n'a vraiment
pris le risque de l'attaqué puisque
monsieur chomsky s'est proposé un peu
comme le le nouveau merkel quelque part
paradoxalement olaf scholz qui apparaît
peu plus populaires même même en bavière
où traditionnellement les conservateurs
sont forts
oui tout à fait donc il y à il ya un
phénomène chose c'est à dire que les je
pense que dans la dent graincourt cette
campagne les le débat s'est beaucoup
personnalisée c'est à dire que faute de
se porter vraiment sur les thèmes et le
détail des programmes il s'est porté sur
les personnes et dans ce contexte c'est
quelque chose qui a profité à monsieur
jones qui apparaît comme le le peuple le
candidat le plus mûr le plus expérimenté
et en même temps le plus rassurant et ça
ça a été pour lui un bonus et il a aussi
donc il a donc remporté empoché 1 une
plus value par rapport à la faiblesse de
ses de ses concurrents olaf scholz
colisée pour le moment favori une colo
une coalition doit désormais se former
entre les différents partis ils se
réunissent aujourd'hui à berlin savez
une coalition difficile quels sont les
scénarios les plus probables possibles
et bien
skié au jour ce qui sera déterminant
dans cette dans cette constellation ce
sera la khl a la capacité
de
dudu de celui titille les petits sera
désignée chancelière à
établir sa centralité et donc il faudra
être capable de
rapprocher non seulement les verts mais
les libéraux qui gît ont des programmes
relativement divergent sur notamment les
questions de finances publiques
et les questions
disons 2 rythme et d'intensité à mettre
dans la transition climatique donc les
discussions seront très difficiles parce
que c'est un peu un assemblage de
contraire et la tâche du futur
chancelier sera précisément
de pouvoir sécuriser un programme
qui ignore qui permettent à cet attelage
au départ peu
homogène de fonctionner de manière
efficace sur quatre ans donc c'est un
véritable défi et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut s'attendre à des à des discussions
relativement longue pour pouvoir boucler
ce programme et mais quand on est martin
d'un mot seulement qui sera
l'interlocuteur des grandes puissances
pour l'instant gala merkel
oui puisque la la la règle veut que le
gouvernement sortant continue à expédier
les affaires courantes jusqu'à ce que le
bundestag et nuls le successeur le
nouveau gouvernement donc il y aura
toujours quelqu'un qui répondra au
téléphone à berlin et les affaires sont
suivis et géré par une équipe
expérimentée l'équipe sortante si vous
couvrirez qu andré martin pour toutes
ces précisions et d'avoir répondu en
direct à nos questions ce matin sur rtl
france merci